BRIDGE COLLAPSE.
IF NEWS BREAKS OUT THE MOBILE
BREAK-IN.
I'M TRACE GALLAGHER, NOW BACK TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT" ."
>> Tucker: AND THE LAST YEAR,
THIS IS A RECENTLY NEW THING,
THE AMERICAN WEST HAS UNITED
BEHIND A NEW THEORY.
ANYONE COULD COME HERE FOR ANY
REASON AND ONCE THEY'RE HERE,
THEY NEVER HAVE TO LEAVE NO
MATTER WHAT THE ORIGINAL
JUSTIFICATION FOR BEING HERE IS.
IF YOU DISAGREE, YOU ARE A
BIGOT.
THE U.S. HAS A DESIGNATION
CALLED TEMPORARY PROTECTIVE
STATUS FOR IMMIGRANTS IN CERTAIN
COUNTRIES.
WE HAVE THIS BECAUSE WE ARE KIND
COUNTRY, WE TRY TO HELP.
THE STATUS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
SHORT-TERM MEASURE LETTING
PEOPLE REMAIN IN THE U.S. OF
THEIR COUNTRY SUFFERS A CALAMITY
LIKE A NATURAL DISASTER,
EARTHQUAKE, WHATEVER.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
A LONG TIME AND IT HAS BEEN
BADLY ABUSED.
ONE-THIRD OF ALL SALVADORANS ON
THE GLOBE NOW LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HONDURAN IMMIGRANTS HAVE ENJOYED
STATUS SINCE 1998.
THE TRIP ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
TEMPORARY, LET'S MAKE IT
TEMPORARY AND LET THE STATUS IS
OF SOME COUNTRIES EXPIRE.
THE LEFT IS REVEALING WHAT THEY
REALLY THINK, THEY WERE ACTUALLY
PERMANENT ALL ALONG.
SEVERAL IMMIGRANTS ARE SUING THE
TRIP IT ADMINISTRATION SAYING
THEY CAN'T BE DEPORTED.
THEY'RE CLAIMING THE PRESIDENT
HAS DESCRIBED SOME COUNTRIES AS
TERRIBLE PLACES TO LIVE,
THEREFORE HE IS A BIGOT.
NEVER MIND HIM LETTING THEM COME
HERE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE ONLY THING THAT MATTERS IS
THE SINGLE PRINCIPLE TO THE
LEFT, ANYBODY CAN LIVE IN THE
U.S. AND THEY SHOULD NEVER BE
FORCED TO LEAVE EVER, WE THINK
THAT'S THE PRINCIPLE, BUT TO
EXPLAIN IT TO US, WE HAVE THE
LEGAL DIRECTOR OF THE ACELLULAR
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
THESE PLAINTIFFS ARE SAYING IT
WAS NEGATIVE OF THE PRESIDENT TO
DESCRIBE THESE COUNTRIES AS "
"HOW DOES IT WORK?
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S QUITE
HOW WE SEE IT.
THE GOVERNMENT CAN TRADE A
TEMPORARY PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE FOR
SIX, 12, 18 MONTHS.
THESE ARE COUNTRIES WHERE PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN LAWFULLY RESIDING FOR
ALMOST 20 YEARS.
ALL WE'RE SAYING IS WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT WANTS TO CHANGE THE
PROGRAM AND TAKE AWAY THEIR
STATUS, TEAR APART THEIR
FAMILIES, THEIR U.S. CITIZEN
CHILDREN WHO ARE IN HIGH SCHOOL,
THEY HAVE A VERY GOOD REASON TO
DO THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE A VERY GOOD
REASON HERE.
>> Tucker: IF THIS WASN'T
PERMANENT RESETTLEMENT OF PEOPLE
WHO WANTED A BETTER STANDARD OF
LIVING.
THIS SPECIFIC PROGRAM WAS TO
SATE YOUR COUNTRY IS A DISASTER,
YOU CAN COME HERE UNTIL IT'S
BETTER.
ONE-THIRD OF ALL SALVADORANS WHO
LIVE HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
WHY IS IT UNFAIR TO HOLD UP TO
THE STANDARDS WE AGREED ON IN
THE FIRST PLACE?
>> TWO THINGS, TUCKER.
FIRST, IT'S ON THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER OR NOT YOU HAVE A GOOD
REASON TO TERMINATE IT.
IT'S DID THE GOVERNMENT HAVE A
REASON HERE?
WE KNOW THERE WAS A BIPARTISAN
PROPOSAL, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS ARE PROPOSED TO THE
PRESIDENT GRANTING PERMANENT
RESIDENCY BECAUSE THEY LIVED
HERE FOR SO LONG AND HE REJECTED
THAT IN THIS MEETING WHERE HE
HAD THIS COMMENT, I DON'T KNOW
IF I'M ALLOWED TO SAY THIS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT RELEVANT
BECAUSE NONE OF THAT BECAME LAW.
HE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
SOMEONE.
IT'S NOT REALLY RELEVANT.
YOU ARE SAYING IT CAN'T BE
TEMPORARY BECAUSE WHY?
>> IT CAN BE TEMPORARY.
THE POINT IS THIS HAPPEN FOR A
LONG TIME, SOME OF OUR PLANTAINS
ARE A 14-YEAR-OLD HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS BORN AND RAISED IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA, A STUDY IN
GOVERNMENT, STUDYING THE
CONSTITUTION AND KNOWS THAT THE
DUE PROCESS PROTECTS A PERSON.
SHE NOW HAS TO EITHER LEAVE THE
ONLY COUNTRY THAT SHE'S EVER
KNOWN TO DELIVER HER PARENTS IN
EL SALVADOR OR THE BE BROKEN
APART.
>> Tucker: I FEEL SORRY FOR --
THE QUESTION ALSO IS ARE THEY
SAYING THAT IT WAS RACIST TO
DESCRIBE THEIR HOME COUNTRIES AS
TERRIBLE PLACES OR THAT THEIR
HOME COUNTRIES ARE TERRIBLE
PLACES AND THAT'S WHY THEY CAN
GO BACK?
>> I THINK THE POSITION IF YOU
LOOK AT IT, THE JUSTIFICATIONS
OF GRANTING --
>> Tucker: TRUMPS COMMENTS,
THE ONES WHO ARE REPORTED, I
BELIEVE HE SAID THAT BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE BY THE WAY.
ARE YOU TAKING ISSUE WITH THAT?